find the some 15 plus negative 46 plus
29 so let's just think about this first
part over here where we have 15 plus
negative 46 plus negative 46 and we'll
worry about the plus 29 later on so
let's just do 15 15 plus plus negative
let me do that in a different color plus
negative 46 doing that orange plus
negative 46 so let me draw a number line
here just so we can properly visualize
what is going on so that's my number
line that's my number line we're
starting at 15 so let me put let's draw
a zero over here and so we are starting
at 15 15 could be right over here so
this is 15 when we just draw let me draw
a big fat arrow to signify this is 15 15
has an absolute value of 15 so the
length of this arrow would be 15 now
we're adding negative 46 to that 15 that
is the same thing this is equivalent to
15 minus 46 minus 46 which means we are
going to move 46 spots to the left of 15
negative sign or minus means we're
moving to the left on the number line so
we're going to move 46 to the left so
we're starting at 15 and we are going to
move 46 we are going to move 46 to the
left so the length of this arrow right
here the length of this arrow is going
to be 46 and we're moving to the left
this is the negative 46 that we're
adding to the 15 so we're going to end
up we're going to end up at some point
over here that point is clearly zero
because we're we were 15 to the right
now we're going to move 46 to the left
so we're definitely going to be to the
left of 0 so it's definitely going to be
a negative number and we can even think
about we can even think about the
absolute value of that negative number
we can just visualize it we moved this
yellow arrow as a length of 15 this
orange arrow has a length of 46 the blue
arrow that I'm about to draw which is
the sum of these two is going to be
is going to be right it's going to have
this length right over here and just
visually how could we figure out the
length of this blue part if we know the
length of this orange part and we know
the length of this yellow part which is
going to be the difference it's just
going to be the difference of these two
so the absolute value of the sum is
going to be the difference between this
length 46 and 15 so this is 46 let me
just figure that out 46 minus 15 6 minus
5 is 1 4 minus 1 is 3 so the length of
this is going to be 31 it's going to be
31 to the left of 0 so this is going to
be negative 31 right over here
so we know that this first part over
here is negative 31 and then to that we
are going to add 29 so we're going to
add 29 let me do that in another color
so what does that mean
that means that we're going to start at
negative 31 and we're going to move 29
to the right we're adding 29 so we're
going to move 29 29 to the right so
maybe that gets us right about there
trying to draw an arrow of length 29 let
me draw it
I can draw cleaner-looking arrow than
that I'll do it right over here actually
so then we're going to move 29 over to
the right
that's the 29 part so now this is the
positive 29 and so how do we figure out
what this is so we're just going to this
is going to land us so this number this
is 29 right here that we're adding this
is going to land us right over here on
the number line so how do we figure out
what number that is
well once again we can just visualize
and eventually you won't have to draw a
number lines and stuff but I think it'll
be useful here the number that we're
going to do we're starting at negative
31 we're adding 29 to it so it's going
to make it less negative but we're not
we're still adding less than 31 so we're
not going to get all the way back to 0
so we're still going to have a negative
number so we're still going to have a
negative number but how could we figure
out the absolute value of that negative
number its distance well once again that
little white part right there that white
part plus this 29 is going to equal 31
if you just think of AB
saluté value if we don't think about the
signs if we just think about the length
or another way to think about it 31 - 29
will give us the length of that white
part and of course it's going to be
negative because the negative number
here is larger than the positive number
and we're adding the two so if we do 31
- 29 31 - 29 you you could borrow in all
of that but that's clearly just going to
be equal to - you could say that's 11
this is the - you subtract this is equal
to 2 but since it's negative 31 + 29
it's going to be a negative - we're
still going to stay negative we haven't
moved far to the right enough to pass 0
so this right here is going to be
negative - or another way to think about
the length of this white bar the
absolute value is going to be 2 2 plus
29 is 31 but we're operating to the left
of 0 so it's negative 31 this is
negative 2 anyway hopefully you found
that useful
well anyway let me make it clear so our
final answer is our final answer is
negative is negative 2